it's now been more than a quarter of a
century since Daniel Stern played Marvin
home alone yet it remains his most
recognizable role despite the fact that
he's never stopped acting Stern's stayed
busy so why don't we see him as often
anymore Stern was the narrator on The
Wonder Years between 1988 and 1993 and
he directed a handful of episodes along
the way soon enough he decided he wanted
to take a shot at directing a movie as
well so in 1993 he helmed what would be
his first and last feature the family
baseball comedy Rookie of the Year it's
the story of a 12 year old pitcher who
leads the Chicago Cubs to glory after
discovering that his recently broken arm
has healed with super-strength that's
the sort of logic that you don't think
to question as a kid but the grown-up
critics reviewing the film weren't as
easily impressed despite the poor
reviews the film was a decent box-office
success
racking up over fifty million dollars in
ticket sales stern who also acted in the
movie as pitching coach Phil brickma
went on to direct a few TV episodes here
and there afterwards but Hollywood has
yet to call him back in from the bullpen
the box-office success of the home alone
movies meant that Stern had little
choice but to carry on as a goofball in
other films he reprised his city
slickers role in the 1994 sequel The
Legend of Curly's gold and he handed up
in forgotten comedies like bushwhack and
Celtic pride he then decided to take
radical action to shake off his
typecasting as he signed on for the
controversial 1998 comedy very bad
things the film is about a group of men
on a bachelor weekend trying to dispose
of a prostitute one of them accidentally
killed it was supposed to be edgy but
for the majority of critics it crossed
the line into bad taste far too often
Roger Ebert for one called it
reprehensible in his one-star review
Stern however did think it was funny
telling the a/v Club in a 2014 interview
that he enjoyed it thoroughly but the
gamble didn't exactly pay off for his
career
[Music]
after very bad things Stern's next
credit was a little-known crime caper
called viva los nowhere which failed to
open any new doors for him from the
outside it looked as though his time was
up but while his on-screen career was
floundering he was prospering behind the
scenes as a voice artist Stern did
everything from Burger King and 7up
commercials to Emmy winning shows he
found quite the good fit as the title
character in the TV adaptation of the
Dilbert comic strip between 1999 and
2000 his other notable voice credits
include the likes of Hey Arnold and
Family Guy perhaps the biggest reason
most of us haven't seen Daniel Stern in
a long time is that he went through a
six-year stretch without appearing in
any feature films his last credit before
2018 came in 2012 when he returned to
the realm of festive comedy with a
Christmas story - but this was no home
alone however far from it in fact a
straight-to-dvd sequel to a much-loved
Yuletide classic A Christmas Story 2 was
released just days before a musical
version of the original was set to debut
on Broadway Warner Brothers was likely
attempting to cash in on the hype
surrounding the stage production
unfortunately hardly anyone noticed and
the few critics that bothered to review
the film were less than enthusiastic
about it in 2018 Stern made a not so
glorious return to the screen in the
Netflix original game over man starring
the workaholics guys as hotel
housekeepers who find themselves in a
die hard scenario the reviews were
pretty much just as dreadful as they
were for a Christmas story - I'll make
it up let me just get my head together
and we'll talk about it all right
Stern might be proud of his own career
accomplishments but that's nothing
compared to what he felt after helping
his son become the youngest California
state senator in history in 2016 the
then 34 year old Henry Stern won the
honor of representing the 27th district
which stretches from Malibu to the Santa
Clarita Valley a Democrat the younger
Stern is the first millennial to make it
to the California Senate and he plans on
representing his age group well during
his term one of Henry's biggest
supporters on the trail was his father
who had regularly turned up to support
him in campaign events and endorse him
via social media
when Henry won the elder stern could
barely contain his joy revealing that he
cried when the children's choir began
singing at the swearing
and ceremony in an Instagram post he
wrote I have done all I can for my own
children and they are children no more
[Music]